yeah I do agree with that believe the
government should be open I think the
worst example was when the vice
president said he wasn't going to submit
to the scrutiny of Congress when they
asked them for documents and then
outrageously he said that he was not
going to provide him because he wasn't a
member of the executive branch and I
said to myself well what is he a farmer
my point is that when it comes to
national security when it comes to just
simple information I'll give you an
example I got into a little trouble when
I said at one of the debates that on
UFOs aliens I don't believe in them but
one of the problems that have been
compounded about propagating this myth
that aliens exist in Roswell New Mexico
was because the government has not
provided full disclosure of incidents
that happened years ago about possible
landings in Roswell New Mexico and if
they just released all the information
they wouldn't have had this problem yeah
I do believe in general government is
very secretive it's very bureaucratic in
many cases it turns people off it's very
impersonal and one of the one of the
objectives I would have is to make the
government more more friendly to people
more responsive to people I would do
that by leading by example I would look
at everything that needed to be de
classified national security domestic
and I would say this is the first step
we're going to do secondly I would also
say to the American people i'm going to
give you access to your president I
think the president is a symbol of
American government and leadership what
i would do is i submit to unfettered
town meetings with the American people
I'd have office hours where ordinary
people could come to see me as long as
it were five minutes and they didn't
carry a weapon actually I've done that
as governor I would make the White House
more part of the American family make it
more accessible obviously a president
has to worry about
but i would spend night in people's
homes just trying to explain that
government can be on the side of the
american people one of our big problems
has been that the american people think
that government is simply is not on
their side that government is there to
block progress that government is there
to make things more difficult more
bureaucratic a lot of it is the tone of
leadership that a president would break